y el hecho de que pongo idol nos dijeron
que no iba a hacer el anuncio de la
participación pero todavía no está
confirmado si él va a participar o no lo
que sí se sabe es que su partido
voluntad popular si va a participar en
estas elecciones pero hay algo que
quiero destacar es que ese boicot que de
2018 de esta oposición no ha querido
participar es porque venezuela es un
país que no es democrático y ninguna de
las elecciones funcionan como debería de
funcionar y esta decisión de que cambió
el rumbo o algo que ya había sido norma
la participación de las elecciones es
porque el contexto internacional cambio
mayor donald trump que esté empujando y
que tenga la narrativa mucho más directa
con respecto al régimen de venezuela
sino que hay un río guaire que se enfoca
mucho más en la multilateralidad y está
empujando las elecciones entonces esto
podría verse como el resultado de
también en la mesa de negociación de
méxico en la que la oposición busca
cambiar un rumbo pero no veo que sea
algo empate directamente la política
personal a favor de la posición porque
incluso esta tarjeta en la que se está
postulando es algo que dejó a la
posición para que se postulara pero
ninguna de las tarjetas de los partidos
principales en voluntad popular primero
justicia un nuevo tiempo están
legalizadas en el país y también muestra
una indecisión por parte de la oposición
en la participación puesto que incluso
el cnt tuvo que dar un día extra para
que participar también hay que tener en
cuenta que el problema venezolano no es
electoral y tampoco la solución
electoral es sólo una parte dentro del
contexto grande de autoritarismo que
vive venezuela y son unas elecciones
regionales que nos representan
directamente una amenaza a el poder
maduro
precisamente por eso estamos avanzando
también con la información sobre las
negociaciones que se dan en méxico y
quiero preguntarle ya para cerrar muy
rápidamente si existen para usted en
realidad garantías para que la oposición
participe en los próximos comicios no
hay garantías tampoco espero que haya
concesiones en el corto plazo con
respecto a estas elecciones hay
garantías mínimas que ya consiguieron
mucho antes y este proceso nicolás no lo
está buscando que la oposición participe
en los otros procesos electorales él
mismo creó la oposición y ahora está
creando incentivos para que mucha parte
de la oposición participe dejando a un
lado juan guaidó que es el contrincante
mucho más fuerte y que le ha ocasionado
molestias por así decirlo en los últimos
años no tengo ninguna expectativa de que
se convierta en unas elecciones
medianamente libres además que son
elecciones regionales elecciones que
dentro de un país totalmente
centralizado no no significan una
amenaza para el poder